흠 흠 흫
헉
오랜만인데
크흠
고치고
하하하하하
안녕하십니까
비주류 초대석
호스트를 맡은
김관지
uk것입
아
트릴로지의 마지막을 하러 모였는데요 저희가 영화월드컵을 2편을 했잖아요 그래서 제가 듣기로 허키님한테 GV섭외가 그렇게 많이 온다고
들었어요 실제로 하신 것도 있으세요? 아니 없어요 아직 없는데 왜 다 거절하고 계신가요?
이제 너무 정신이 없어서 거절하고 있긴 하지만 좀 이게 새로운 어떤 경험이네요
GV? GV 민경님 실제로 GV 지금 자주 다니시잖아요 아 네 저도 혼자서 아예 그냥 무슨 GV란 GV 다 가가지고
GV 요정이 됐어? 혼자서 간 건 아니고 하나는 혜진님이랑 하고 하나는 소윤님이랑 다 여기서 이제 아주 영화인이야
둘이 적합하지 않다고 생각하나 봐요 저희를요? 그래서 제가 수혜를 받고 있어요 감사해요 사실은 저는 좀 감사해요 두 분한테
근데 제가 영화관계자인 거 같아요
근데 간지님은 GV 혹시 제안 들어오세요?
안 들어왔어요? 안 들어왔어요 어 진짜래? 초대 뭐지 그 보러 가는 시사회
오 보기만 해라
보고 아 너무 좋아요 이렇게 리스트를 올려주면 돈을 준다고 해가지고
그건 좀 어렵다 그건 좀 너무 어려워서 관문이 많잖아요 뭘 해야 되는지 모르겠어요
GV 제안이 들어오면 하실 의향이 있으시죠?
저희 뭐 시간 맞고 이러면 되는데
저는 그리고 원래 GV를 좋아해요 하는 거를
해본 적이 있으세요?
두 번
본인 출연한 영화를?
내 거를 해봤어요
슈퍼디스크 말씀하시는 거에요?
네 맞습니다
어느 영화에 나오셨어요?
슈퍼디스크
슈퍼디스크 안 보셨어요?
나 안 봤지
그걸 안 봤어요?
진짜로요?
그거 안 보고 지금 이 자리에 앉은 거예요?
나 겸상 안 해
순둥이가 편집해주세요
미방분도 하나 더
테이블 따로 만들어주세요
민경 님도 이번 주제 걱정하셨다고
아 네 맞아요
저희가
저희 다 그런가요?
저는 확실한데
외국 영화를 좋아합니다
저도 외국 영화를 좀 더 많이 본 거 같더라고요
이번 걸 준비하면서 생각해 보니까
우리가 한국인이지만
마음은 미국인인데
아니요
저는 한국 영화 꽤 많이 봤어요
아 그래요?
토익 몇 점이에요?
토익이요?
네
400...
20점인가?
토익 몇 점이에요?
나는 900은 넘어요
미국인이네
아니요
사태주의에 찌들어가지고
그래서 해외 문학을 보고
해외 문학 편집자가 된 건가요?
굳이 그 한국 문학을 놔두고
그 훌륭한 한국 문학
토익을 열심히 해가지고
아 나는 미국 문학
위대하신 미국 문학을
그거예요 지금?
그거예요?
둘이 너무 기고만 정해서 그게...
난 못하겠어
아무나 안 줘줘
일용 님이나 오면 안 돼
여자 한 명만
선착순으로 한 명만 봐줘
친구와 초록물고기
친구는 간지 님 픽
제 픽입니다
초록물고기는 허키 님 픽입니다
친구 진짜 너무 뻔합니다
아 진짜 나는 저거
네가 가라 하와이
아니 어떻게 저게 저 정도로
이게 되게 엄청난 히트였잖아요
저거는 그때 저 시절을 휩쓸었죠
저게 왜 그러냐면은
왜 이렇게 인기가 많았을까요?
네 인기가 많았어요? 왜 이렇게 인기가 많았어요?
그런 영화들이 정말 많잖아요
그중에 이걸 특히 좋아하시는 이유가 있나요?
저거는 진짜 건달 얘기예요
다 건달 얘기지 그럼
이 건달의 우정과 결국에는 서로 간의 배신과
서로 간의 갈등과 이런 것들을
다 한꺼번에 담아낸 영화거든요
근데 말죽거리 잔혹사도 저는 비슷한 계열이라고 보는데
말죽거리 잔혹사는 그래도 조금
청춘이 좀 보여요
왜냐면 막 권상우 씨가 쌍결곤도 연습하고
티격태격 싸우면서 햄버거도 때리고
니가 올라와 이러는데
친구는 그걸 성인까지 보여줘
더 지독하게 만드는 거죠
진짜 리얼리티하게
글쎄요
저 그 말죽거리 잔혹사에
유명한 밈 하나 있는 거 아십니까?
뭐죠?
권상우가 의자 던지면서 하는 거
옥상으로 올라 이거
누가 나한테 우유를 던졌어
누가 더빙한 거요?
저도 그거 좋아요
이 신선한 우유를 만져
한 대 두 대
이 돼지 녀석
나 돼지가 아니야
나도 진짜 좋아요 그거
나 돼지 아니야
두우우우우우 나도 좋아요
나 그거 너무 웃겨가지고
계속 보거든요
요즘에도 봐요
그러니까 그게 말죽거리 잔혹사였으면 좋았을 텐데
친구는 그런 밈이 없긴 해요
친구 있어요
친구는 그때 당시에
그냥 그때 당시에
학교에 가다가
야 하면
어?
말 못다 이거
아유
보통 그냥 간단한 유행어 정도지
이런 어떤 밈역이 좀 부족합니다
제 생각도
아 근데 친구 실화 기반이에요
알 바 아닙니다
누군가 나에게 신선한 우유를 던졌어
이 신선한 우유를 말해
난 그 녀석을 참고 싶다고
자 한 대 두 대 돼지 녀석
난 돼지가 아니야
저도 뭐 인정합니다
제 그냥 개인적인 픽이었고
네 초롱 물고기는
초롱 물고기 올라가야겠죠?
무슨 내용인가요?
내용을 볼 필요가 있나요?
지금 친구가 옆에 있고
그래도
이 정도로 디스했으면 이게 올라가야죠
그 가운데 남자분
매트리스 가짜 아니에요 저거?
그 댓글 기억나세요?
가운데 남자분 너무 성의 없는 거 아닌가요?
아니 근데 올리고 난 다음에 설명할 수 있잖아
일단 올리는데
어떤 내용인지 설명을 좀 해주시죠
아이고 괜찮아요
정말 별로예요
97년에 나온 이창동 감독님의 영화입니다
초롱 물고기
막동이라는 친구
한석규가 맡은 캐릭터가 이제
전역을 해요
전역을 하는 기차 안에서
저 보스의
와이프인지 뭔진 잘 모르겠지만
그분을 첫 만남을 해요
그래서 와 미녀다 이러고 보고 있다가
어떠한 계기로
지금 문성근 씨가 지금 저 보스거든요
저기서
그분 밑에서 일하게 돼요
둘 다 조폭 영화인데
그러니까 또 깡패 영화인가요?
네 근데 이제 거기서 일하게 되면서 생기는
내용입니다
뭐 내용 이 정도면 된 거 아니에요?
친구 올리죠
그러니까 너무 성의가 없는데요 내용이
성의가 없는데 친구 올리자 그냥
저는 어릴 때 막 출발 비디오 여행
그런 데서 그 장면만 본 기억이 나요
전화받는 장면
아 그게 너무 명장면이라
그게 되게 유명한 장면이잖아요
그러니까
거기서 한석규 배우가 연기를 너무 잘해가지고
보고 있으면 좀 되게 와 너무 멋있다
결론을 내주시죠
한 달 두 건달 중에 한 무리만 올라가야 됩니다
친구 같은 경우에 너무 이거를
저 깡패들의 세상을 너무 그 낭만화한 느낌이 좀 있잖아요
네
우리나라 조폭영화의 시작 아니었나요?
맞습니다
그는 제일 싫어하는 걸 시작하신 건데
그래서 저도 제가 싫어요
근데 이거는 되게 현실적인 어떤
그럼 초록물고기 물고기로 가시죠
네 초록물고기 올리겠습니다
물고기 올라가 봐 너도 곧 추락하게 될 거야
아 저희 그래서 나쁜 영화도 봤습니다
새로 보셨어요?
네
아 진짜요?
저는 이 보고서
허키가 진짜 병석 중이긴 하구나. 왜요? 이거 왜? 너무 힙해요. 아 힙하다? 지금 보니까. 너무 너무.
그렇게 접근하는구나 또. 아 힙하다. 이건 옴니버스 식인데 90년대에 불량 청소년들과 불량 학생들, 가출 청소년들을 쫓아다니면서
다큐멘터리처럼. 근데 그게 페이크 다큐멘터리. 다큐가 아니에요. 너무 진짜같은. 다큐멘터리처럼 찍어서 정말 다큐처럼 보이는데.
뭔가 사회적 이상한 것들을 다 보여주는 그런 다큐 같은 영화. 문제작이죠. 문제작이죠. 그리고 그때 당시에 97년에 제일 날라리와 제일 우리가 흔히
말하는 불량배들의 진짜 삶을 이제 녹여내려고 노력을 많이 했고. 진짜 같아요. 그리고 이때 당시에 제일 인디스러운 음악들을 여기다 다 넣어놨어요.
이 나쁜 영화라는 제목 자체도 사실은 저 삐삐 밴드 노래에서 아마 나온 걸까요?
어업 밴드도 있었고 황신혜 밴드 짬뽕도 나왔던 것 같고. 저는 되게 좋게 봤습니다.
재밌어요. 힙하다? 간지님의 평이였어요. 저는 완전히 힙하다고 생각해요.
저는 이렇게 힙한 거는 처음 봤어요. 진짜 잘 만들었다니까요. 근데 좀 흥미롭게 들었어요. 한번 보고 싶긴 하네요. 한번 보셔도 나쁘지 않습니다.
1987은 민경님 핀이죠? 네. 제가 고른 영화입니다. 저는 사실 이런 실화 기반, 역사적인 사실이 있는 영화를 막 그렇게 좋아하지는 않아요.
근데 그런 영화들 중에서도 이 영화는 좀 잘 만들었다고 생각해서 그 마지막 장면에 그 광장에서 사람들이 막 시위하는 장면으로 끝날 때 감흥이 있더라고요.
1987. 뭐가 올라가야 될까요? 이건 뭐.
나쁜 영화인 것 같아요. 저도 근데 약간 흥미가 생겨서 나쁜 영화 올릴까.
왜냐면 1987도 훌륭한 영화지만. 문제적 감독의 문제적 영화. 왜 이렇게 문제가 있고 이런 걸 늘 좋아? 그런 거에 끌리시는 거예요?
사실 제가 솔직하게 말씀드리면 제 자체가 문제가 없어요. 문제가 되고 싶거든요.
그런 것 같더라고요. 왜냐면 지난번 편을 봤어요. 뭐요? 뭐였죠? 반려동물 편을 봤어요. 그러고 나서 나는 그걸 집에서 TV로 보면서 생각을 많이 했어요.
어떤 생각을 하셨어요? 아 저 자식들 이거 완전 이거 코스프레였구나 그동안. 마지막에 간지 님은 우시더라고요. 편집됐던데.
아니 그게 좀 오해가 있는 게 너무 힘들어가지고.
아 그걸 보면서 아 굉장히 기믹이고 코스프레였다. 사실은 그냥 소시민들이구나. 40대 아저씨들.
아니 그 조합이라는 걸 잘 이제 생각을 해보시면 어떤 사람이 옆에 앉아 있느냐에 따라서.
그래서 그 너무 이제.
좀 보편적인 그런 40대 아저씨들이셔서 이런 영화에 끌리시는 것 같아서.
와 이거 좀 이거 비하가나니.
네 이거 올리겠습니다. 아저씨들 취향에 맞게.
자 미량. 이거 민경 님 피고. 영자의 전성시대.
이것도 영자원.
영자원 가면 저거 볼 수 있어요.
어떤 내용이죠?
내용은 이제 잘 기억이 안 나는데요. 사실. 내용은 기억이 안 나요. 그냥 그 분위기만 기억이 납니다. 이것도 이제 또 서울의 그 옛 시절을.
네.
이건 70년대로 넘어갑니다.
내가 모르는 시대.
영자는 뭐 하시는 분인가요?
영자는 이제 그 술집에서 일하시는 분. 그래서 거기서 힘들게 살아가는 그 청춘들의 이야기. 근데 로맨스 영화입니다. 그리고 안성기 배우님의 어린 시절을 볼 수 있습니다.
최불암 형님도 나오고. 참 특이한 게 최불암 형님은 저 75년 째 학인데 그때도 할아버지 역할을 하셨어요. 우리나라의 모건 프리먼 같은.
네.
지금 봐도 내용이 되게 재밌어요. 제가 자신 있게 얘기할 수 있습니다. 여러분 유튜브에서 공짜로 시청하십시오.
좋습니다.
네.
미량은 뭐?
저는 이 영화 너무 좋아요.
저도 좋아요. 근데.
이창동 감독님 영화 중에 저는 단연 최고로 뽑습니다.
음.
인정.
이거는 뭐 어떤 부분이 제일 좋았나요?
그 전도연이 중간에 교회에 빡쳐가지고.
네.
교회에서 무슨 야외 행사 같은 거 하거든요.
응.
거짓말이야.
그때 거짓말이야 노래 틀어버려요. 그 기계.
그 펑크 정신.
락.
락 스피릿.
저항.
그리고 그때 말해서 또 통편 또 되겠지만. 그래서 여기서 저는 송강호가 연기를 제일 잘했다고 생각해요. 카센터 사장 연기.
음.
최고였죠.
전도연의 뒤에서 이렇게 보필하는.
네네.
되게 리얼해요. 근데. 리얼한 그런 남자의 모습이었어요. 그리고 그 춤.
그 데이트 신청했을 때 오케이 받았을 때 그 춤 기억나시나요?
어떻게 추죠?
이렇게 하거든요.
그게 어떻게 저런 몸동작이 나올 수가 있나.
이거는 이번에 안 보셨어요?
봤어요. 이거. 옛날에 봤어요.
옛날에?
네. 근데 저는 전도연님 연기가 완전 좀 미쳤다라는 생각밖에 안 들고 나머지는 그냥 재밌다? 응?
지금 변희재 얘기하시고 나서 영 열정이 시켰어요.
영 열정이 식은 느낌인 것 같은데.
영어로 안 보이시죠 지금?
좀만 시간을 주고.
네. 미량 올릴까요?
미량 올리죠.
네.
뭐야 이게. 이렇게 간단하게 올려버린다고?
미량.
아.
아기공룡 둘리랑 극장전인데.
네.
자. 아기공룡 둘리.
이게 그니까 아기공룡 둘리 1987 말고 96년도인가에 한 어른별 대모험이라는 극장판이 있어요.
그거 둘리 엄마 나오는 거잖아.
유일한 극장판 영화.
아 극장판?
그거예요.
분홍색 큰 엄마 나오는 거.
네. 그리고 극장전은 허키님.
저의 픽입니다.
제가 홍상수 감독님의 영화 중에 가장 좋아하는 영화. 극장전.
내용은 똑같습니다.
그런데 이것 좀 다른 게 이제 좀 이거는 이제 극 안에 또 극이 또 벌어져요.
그니까 내용 안에 또 내용이 있는. 혹시 보셨나?
아니요.
이건 좀 재밌을 텐데.
안 볼려고.
추천합니다.
홍상수 감독님 영화 중에서 남주인공이 굉장히 젊고.
젊은 친구가 나오죠. 또 이례적으로.
이 영화를 제일 좋아하시는 이유가 특별히 있으세요?
그 민망함의 리밋을 넘어버렸어요. 으악 소리 지를 뻔했어요. 진짜.
그 정도로?
네. 진짜 최악이다. 이런 거 봤어요. 저 모든 상황.
이해합니다. 저도 홍상수 감독님 영화 봤을 때.
민망해 죽겠다.
좀 신선했거든요.
가만히 있지 못하겠다라고 생각하면서 봤어요. 저건 나다.
아기 공룡 둘리의 좋은 점 좀 설명해 주시죠.
어른별 대모험 혹시 보셨어요?
저 봤어요.
그 2023년인가에 재개봉을 한번 했어요. 포키 리마스터링을 해서.
그때 극장에서 저는 진짜 오랜만에 다시 본 거예요. 어릴 때 보고.
깜짝 놀랐어요. 이거 큰일 났다. 마블에서 다 표절했구나. 어른별 대모험을.
오.
우주로 여행 가서 어떤 행성을 지배하고 있는 지배자를 둘리가 구해낸다. 우주여행을 가서. 이거 완전 어벤져스 내용이잖아요. 그거를 96년, 97년에 했다. 너무 대단하다.
앞서갔다?
가디언즈 오브 갤럭시랑 진짜 똑같아요.
이기고 싶다는 의지가 좀 있는 것 같은데.
저 진짜 이 영화는 진짜 지금 꼭 OTT나 이런 데서 꼭 보셨으면 좋겠어요. 진짜 재밌었어요.
제가 기억하는 거는 엄마가 빙하에 이제 갇혀있는 건데 엄마가 나중에 나와요.
공룡이 나왔거든요. 제 기억에는.
그러니까 엄마라는 게 원래 없었는데 그 분홍색 큰 공룡으로 얼어있는 걸로 엄마가 나와요.
보고픈 엄마 찾아.
그러니까.
모두 함께나 꽃향기를 맡으며.
붕붕. 이거 아닌가?
외로운 둘리.
둘리는 왜 이렇게 외로울까? 근데.
왜냐하면 혼자 깨어나서 그래요. 빙하기에서.
MBTI가 좀 이상한 MBTI.
옆에 친구들 많이 있잖아요. 똥치도 있고.
걔네들이 면면을 하나하나 보면은 다 이제 주류가 되지 못한 비주류들이에요. 다 아웃사이더들.
둘리? 일단 시대를 잘못 깨우는 아기 공룡이죠.
변이제 선거 캠프 같은 느낌이 있어요.
고길동이 이렇게 품어주는 느낌이.
고길동 아저씨가 좀 츤데레가 있죠.
근데 지금 다시 보면 츤데레도 아니야. 그냥 무한정으로 다 받아줘요. 엄청 잘해줘요.
제일 섬특한 게 어른들 대모험 가서 고길동이 어쩌다가 자기는 가고 싶지 않았는데 가서 모험을 하고 다시 돌아와요.
그 쿠키 영상 같은 거에 8일 결근해서 회사에서 혼나는 장면이 나와요.
완전.
완전 진짜 하이퍼 리얼리즘.
저 사람들이. 쟤네들이 엄청나게 괴롭혔네요. 그럼 고길동 아저씨를.
진짜 제가 너무 좋아하는 장면도 있어요.
그 어른별을 지금 지배하고 있는 나쁜 사람. 비호킹이 고길동이랑 마이콜을 잡아와요.
마이콜이 슬퍼서 마지막 노래를 불러요. 간다 이렇게 하고.
막 슈퍼스타일 꿈을 벌이고 이렇게 했는데 비호킹이 너무 그 노래부터 듣고 감명받아서 황실 가수로 임명한다 이러고 풀어줘요.
그래서 고길동이 옆에서 이렇게 잡혀있다가 어 이렇게 하면 풀려나는구나.
그래서 쨍. 이렇게 한 다음에 종로로 갈까요.
비호킹이 감동했네.
영동으로 갈까요.
감동했네.
차라리.
쯔지 왜굽는 사람.
이 정도로 이제.
맨날 뭘 준비해온단 말이야.
그러니까 이것 때문에 우습게 볼 수가 없거든요.
그래. 너네 춤 연습했어. 안 하잖아.
안 하죠.
마더.
둘리 올리죠.
그래서 춤 췄으니까 둘리 올립시다.
아니야.
근데 이거 너무.
순두님 오늘 회식해요.
아 진짜.
하면 좋죠.
이 형이 자기 때문에 하는.
너무 하고 싶어요.
아니 나 미안해서 나 때문에.
하고 싶은데 남들은.
퇴근하고 싶은데 못하는 건가 봐.
아니야. 오늘 실망하는 분들.
그리고.
오늘 마치기 전에.
여러분들이 극장에서 영화를 보셨으면 하는 마음에.
저희가 알고 있는 영화관 몇 개를 좀 소개해 드리려고 해요.
전국 각지에 있는.
일단 아트나인 이수메가박스 건물 12층에 있다고 합니다.
근데 저 여기 이 극장 되게 좋아해요 .
저도 좋아해요.
많이 갔고.
여기서 가끔씩.
올나잇 하잖아요.
하루에 영화를 3개를 틀어줘요, 밤새.
그거 한 번 보러 갔었는데
영화 내용 기억 하나도 안 나는데 되게 재밌었어요.
저는 살인자..
살인마 제계집을 여기서 봤습니다.
그 다음.
무비랜드.
아 들어봤어요.
그 감도 높은 큐레이션 하는 데잖아요.
그 예약이 빡세서 못 들어갔어요.
저기 왜 김민경은 없나요?
왜죠?
감도가 지금 높은 게 많나요, 저기?
지금 김민경 있어야 되네.
김민경이 있어야..
서울 신촌에 있는 필름 포럼.
연세대 2대 서강대 시내필들의 성지라고 하네요.
저기는 안 가봤어요.
한 번 가보고 싶네요.
시내필들의 성지라고 하시네요.
성지 또 저희가 술래해야 되거든요.
괜히 한 번 출몰해보고 싶긴 하네요, 저기.
저희가 가서 너희에게 가르침을 주러 왔노라.
넘어갈게요.
헤이리시네마.
경기 파주네요, 여긴 또.
30석의 소규모 단관극장.
거기도 안 가본 것 같아요.
헤이리가 실제로 가면 되게 재밌습니다.
저쪽에 또 이제 특이한 가게들도 많고
동네도 되게 예쁘고.
한번 좀 추천드립니다.
저는 가본 적이 없지만, 이 극장을.
파주 출판단지도 한 번 들르시고.
영화 보러 가시면.
아울렛에서 이제 밥 먹고.
맞아요.
자유로 한 번 드라이브하고 가고.
그렇게 코스 딱 하면 좋겠다.
거기 유명한 막국수집 있잖아요.
심악산 막국수인가?
다들 그 얘기 하더라고요.
그거 엄청 맛있어요.
네, 한 번 꼭.
아니면 천국장 맛있는 집 있어요.
구산정인가?
진짜 맛있어요.
거기도 꼭 가보시고.
네, 다음.
강릉 독립예술극장 신영.
강원도 강릉이네요.
강원 지역 최초의 독립예술영화 전용관이랍니다.
오, 멋있는데요?
또 의미가 있네요, 그러면.
강릉.
강릉 가시면 또 짬뽕 순두부 먹으면 좋아요.
진짜 유명한 집 있어요.
교동회관인가?
그리고 서핑 같은 거.
원데이 클래스로.
배우실 수 있는 데도 있고.
바나나 보트.
그리고 거기가 커피 대결하고 있거든요.
테라로사도 있고.
커피가 맛있는 집이 많아서 들리시면 좋겠습니다.
배고픈데요?
배고프네요.
자, 무사히 독립영화관.
경남 부산에 있고요.
작은 독립서점 무사히 책방에서 운영하는 독립영화관이라고 합니다.
제가 부산은 부산영화제 때문에 가는데
그래도 독립영화관은 안 가본 것 같아요.
저런 게 있는지 몰랐네요.
그다음.
1D 플러스 천안.
충남 유일의 독립예술영화 전용관.
이건 좀 아쉽네요.
근데 좀 유일이라고 하니까.
맞아. 지방에 살면 진짜 그 독립영화 보기가 정말 힘들어요.
그러니까 서울까지 올라와야 보통 볼 수 있을 텐데.
안동중앙아트시네마.
경북 북부지역 유일의 예술영화 전용관.
경북이 진짜 넓은데 유일하다는 게 진짜 좀 충격이네요.
대구오호극장.
경북대구.
2015년 설립된.
대구 유일의 독립영화 전용관.
여기도 유일이네요, 대구에.
저런 로컬 독립영화가 많아지면 좋겠다.
광주독립극장.
전라도 광주에 있고요.
2018년 개관한 광주독립영화제에서 진행하는 극장입니다.
저긴 가 봤어요.
무슨 일로?
슈퍼디스코.
슈퍼디스코로도 여기 뭐 어딘가 간 거 같은데
제가 그건 기억이 안 나고.
광주 독립극장이 이제 없어진다고 그래서.
집기 빼오라고 간 거예요?
아니요.
ㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋ
사라질까봐 버티고 있는 광주 극장과 코로나 때 사라지는 인디 뮤지션들의 모습이 비슷하다고 생각해서
광주 극장에서 버텨내고 존재하기라는 프로젝트의 공연과 영화를 찍습니다. 그래서 제가 이제 하는 다른 밴드로도 가서 공연을 한번 한 적이 있었는데
생각보다 굉장히 크고 오래됐고 이 옛날 영화관의 그 풍경과 이 냄새랑 이런걸 한꺼번에 확 느낄 수가 있어요.
거기 가보면 특이한 것들도 많고 거울이랑 집게들 같은게 탐나는게 많더라구요.
네 여러분 독립영화관 극장도 전국 방방곡부에 있는 곳을 저희가 소개를 드렸는데요.
한국영화와 독립영화 다 많이 사랑해 주시고요. 다같이 인사하면서 끝낼까요?
네.
어떻게 인사하죠?
머니 그라피!
안녕 평범하게 안녕 할까요? 하나 둘 셋 안녕.
수고하셨습니다.